hello everybody
today i will discuss improved decoding
of expander codes
so this is short term from university of
science and technology of china
based on joint work with quantum
from peking university shinny from
george hawkins university and mingo yang
from peking university
let us review some basic facts about the
coding theory
so given a battery code of learner's
earned
with code words c1 tlc
c1 c2 and so on we define its distance
to be
the minimum hamming distance among all
pairs in c
and its rate to be log the size of c
over the nurse's
okay so
so one factor that will be extensively
used in this talk
is that given the distance say delta
the unique decoding radius of this code
up to uh it's
the distance delta over two
for adversarial errors okay
so we will consider expanded codes in
this talk so let me first
define
the expander
so
expander has two map two parameters
the size of the subset of n and the
expression one minus epsilon b
okay so we call a bipolar type graph
with n vertices on the left and m
vertices on the right
well
it is
d regular on the left hand side
is
uh offer a one minus epsilon d expander
only if
for any subset s of size of the most
offer earned on the left hand side its
neighbor side is neighbor set called
gamma s
is of size but it is the size of s
times the expansion parameter one minus
f of d
okay
so the two parameters of the expander
the first one alpha and
controls the size of the subset s the
second one expansion
know about
know about the size of its member set
in proportion to the size of s okay
so one
comment
is that there's a trivial upper bound on
the neighbor set
that's d times the size of s because the
graph is irregular on the right-hand
side
so expander
means that
every subset of size less than alpha and
has a highly non-trivial lower bound
compared to this trivial upper bound
details s
a few more remarks about the parameters
usually we think m
is a is a constant less than one times n
say m is half of m in this torque
and alpha is also a constant
okay
then
for the parameter epsilon is expansion
so epsilon is the most half
in this talk and some results
require epsilon to be less than one
so the so then this degree d on the left
hand side it will be a constant depends
on alpha and x
so and we
know exclusive constructions with
such
parameters exist from previous wall
by alone
problem
and rainbow valley have
but that's all i want to say about the
expanders so next
let me define expander codes which are
well known for the
actual efficient decoding algorithms
okay so given
the expander
with net with the vertices on the left
and m vertices on the right we define
its expanded code
by assigning
one variable y i
to each vertex on the left and then
constitute
each vertex under one as a priority
check on its labels
so for example
the second will take voltaics on the
right
will be a parity check on y1 and y4
so then
the expanded code associate or
corresponding to this
expander
is all
binary strings as earth satisfies
all parity checks
okay
so one
observation here is that the rate of
this code is at least a minus n
dividing
so one more common is that expanded
codes are closely related to ldpc codes
so while
ldpc codes
require
the fiber type graph to be
bonded or regular
on the right hand side
one can show
that a random ldpc code
will be a
expander code with very good parameters
with a very high probability all right
okay so that's the definition of
expanded code
so now let me tell you some previous
results the feminine work by simpson
spielman
shows a linear attempt decoding
algorithm called the brief propagation
for expander codes
so specifically
given the parameter epsilon less than
one total
the algorithm
can decode one minus two epsilon times
alpha and errors for any expander
code well the parameters of the expander
is alpha n and one minus epsilon times e
okay
so the first comment is that
this algorithm shows that
expanded codes
is a sympathetically good code with
linear time decoding algorithms
so in fact
to the best of my knowledge
all known
symbolically good codes with the new
time decoding algorithms
are
variants of expanded codes okay so
that's one reason where
the second thing is that
it is a folklore that the distance of
the expander code is at least two times
one minus epsilon times alpha
so you can see
there is a gap
like epsilon between the decoding radius
of cypher and fieldman
and the
half of this folklore distance bomb okay
then there are some previous
works by feldman americans the radio
staying red rain white and the madman
separately
[Music]
that provide decoding algorithms with us
with a better radius
one minus three epsilon over one or one
minus two f times alpha
however you can still you can see a gap
between this new radius
and the half of the folklore distance
okay so while we are interested in
improving
the equality radiance
the first motivating question that we
want to figure out in this work is that
what is the best distance bound we can
get from an arbitrary expander
now i can tell you our main result
our first result
shows
a better bond for
any expanded code
okay so basically
given any epsilon less than half the
distance
of any
expander with parameters alpha m one
minus epsilon b
will have its
code with distance
at least alpha and over two epsilon
minus a constant
okay
okay the first comment is that
this distance
alpha over 2 epsilon is always better
than 4 log 1
2 times 1 minus epsilon alpha
for any epsilon necessary
by our title expression okay
so in fact
this is
much larger than the folklore
where
is penny
say
not say
greater than
greater than the focus
by a factor of all the one minus pixel
we also show this is tight
that this expanded the code has distance
alpha over 2 epsilon plus little
that's all i want to
say about
first theorem
then given the new bond on the distance
of the expanded code
the next question will be can we design
ultra efficient algorithms
that decode more errors in particular
if if epsilon is small can we decode
like errors in the order of alpha and or
epsilon instead of some constant times
okay
so we give a firm answer for this
question
so we designed
a linear time algorithm
that
given alpha and epsilon as the one
quarter it decodes
three alpha over 16 epsilon terms and
arrows for any expanded code okay
the first comment is that since the
arrow is in the order of alpha over
epsilon
[Music]
which is better than the previous
decoding radius
by a factor in the order of e
while over if strong if epsilon is small
but even when epsilon is large say close
to one quarter this is still a constant
factor better than the previous results
so it will uh so when epsilon is close
to one quarter our decoding radius is
is
basically three quarters times alpha m
all previous results
can only decode up to half
times alpha and errors
but on the other hand uh
this
feels slightly shorter of decoding half
of the distance that we show
in the previous slide so that's one
quarter times alpha over epsilon
the last thing i want to say about our
results
is that
both serums
will use
this new ingredient
called a size
an expression
so so this number
will say that
any of any expander with parameter alpha
and one minus epsilon b expression
is also expanded for larger subset
but
uh with worse
expression okay so specifically for any
equation one
uh
the expression of the subset of size k
times n
is one minus k
epsilon that's all i want to say about
our results
so the rest of the talk i will first go
over a tagging session i will
sketch the proofs
for stone 2 assuming size expression
tradeoff
and sketch the proof
for level one about the science
expansion trading
but i will tell you some ideas behind
our new decoding
algorithm and finally i will i will give
a summary and tell you some open
problems
just for convenience in the rest of the
talk
we will only consider expanders
whose expansion is at least
three quarters times t
in other words epsilon is less than one
chord
so let me first sketch the proof of
thing two so the basic idea is to
combine the classic
notion or the unique neighbors with our
new ingredient
size and expression with r okay
so first let me define unique labels we
give our subset as
we say a vertex on the right
is a unique name of s only if
this vertex
has exactly one edge connected to s okay
so the first vertex is not a unique
neighbor the second one it is
the third one is not a unique neighbor
neither the first one neither the fourth
one nor the fixed
okay
so now um let me show you a proof sketch
so the
basic fact we will use that
so if the existing unique neighbor
the
in the neighbor side of the
support of a binary string one
zone one is definitely not a good word
because
the parity check of corresponding to
this unique neighbor
will only have one we only have exactly
one one
from
y
okay
at the same time
because
the expanded code is linear if we want
to bound
the distance
of the curve we only need to concede we
only need to consider the uh supposed
size of any known generally battery
stream in this
code okay
so in other words i just want to know
about
the horizons of y and y
so let me first review the argument from
the trivial response to minus two if so
in terms of
so the basic idea is that any software s
sometimes alpha n has at least one minus
two epsilon times d in terms of unique
neighbors from the expression
property
although one can add
at the most one minus two epsilon in
terms of vertices to
say s prime
such that three
there are at least one unique neighbor
left
because
each vertex in s prime
can cure the most d unique neighbors
okay so because there is because as
because there is one unique level left
s union with s prime is not the support
of any
code
so we get a number
so our id will be choose k to be 1 minus
2 epsilon minus negative 1 in level 1
such that number 1 will guarantee that
any t of size k alpha m
has
expression
at least half of the more than half of d
because k is one minus two epsilon minus
negative one okay this is
there's at least one unique neighbor of
t
so that will imply that any y in c will
have both sides of these k
so this is the proof sketch of zero two
so you can see that the number one is
crucial in this proof so then let me
tell you
uh the proof of
number one about the size expansion
trade-off
but the basic idea is to apply a
probabilistic argument about the
conditions
okay
so uh
let me
reformat the number one level one is
saying that given any expander
with guarantee that any subset of size
alpha earned
as expansion one plus epsilon times t
so we can show that any subset of size k
times alpha and
as expansion one minus k epsilon times e
basically we need to show
we need to know about
the size of the neighbor
uh
the size of the neighbor set of any
subsets of size k times alpha m so let's
consider
the fixed subset t of size k alpha m
okay which is shown in the red column
what we know is that
any subset of size alpha has a special
moment of b okay
so two okay so
okay so this works this row so we will
show how to know
the size of gamma t
in this side
so let me tell you uh how we define
lesion
so basically a creation is a pair of
edges
from a fixed subset could be s or t
that have the same
[Music]
white and the pawn when the underpoint
okay
so you can see
for these vertex it has two uh
edges connected to
from s connected to it so there's one
condition
this vertex
there are three edges connected with it
but we do not want to count it as three
choose two conditions we just wanna it
has two conditions
such that
the
size of the neighbor side will be b
times the size of itself minus the
number of creations okay we can define a
proper order
from
our over edges of this subset say s
and
and then
we
by the expression
guarantee we can show that the number of
collisions of s is the most epsilon e
times alpha
h now so now the basic idea is that if t
the largest subset or the superset of t
the supercell of s
has too many conditions
then a random subset will have lots of
cliches which
gives a contradiction to the
above fact okay
so so the basic calculation will show
that if we look at the random s in p of
size alpha n the number of conditions is
at least the number of conditions of t
dividing by a squared because
s is a
s is a subset of basically one k times
um which will be one over k of t
okay
so now i can plug the upper bound of the
number of equations of s on the left
hand side this will help
me up about the number of equations of t
and that will give me the
lower
uh
on the neighbors
that's basically the idea of this
of this science and the expansion paid
off
actually we have better
trade-offs
for larger cases
so finally let me tell you uh our ideas
behind
the new declining algorithm
the key observation
is that we can improve brief propagation
by guessing the expression of the errors
let me review the
parallel algorithm
belief propagation okay
so so so it's very simple so while the
stream y is not a codeword
we will flip all
bits y
with one minus two epsilon d one
text in each label okay and i will do
this flipping in parallel
okay so this is a classic brief
propagation algorithm
so our
key idea is that
if we can guess the expression of y
at every moment say at this moment
the neighbor's set of the supported set
of y
is of size 1 minus gamma times b times
the size of this problem y
for some gamma
less than 2 epsilon 3
then if we reset the threshold of one
priority checks in brief propagation
to one by three gamma d instead of one
minus two epsilon e
it
does decode more errors
okay
okay
then you may ask what if gamma is larger
than three over three
so in the older case we will apply
another another algorithm
that
finds
the error positions
okay
so the final algorithm will be a
combination
of brief propagation and environment
with this new idea of guessing
expressions
so that's what i want to say about our
algorithm
summarize what we did here
the one so we have so our main results
are that the distance of expanded code
is at least of a weight flip so
which is tight
if we if we only have the
expansion gravity
so then
we provide actual efficient decoding
algorithms with radius
three alpha over 16 hips
just for episode
that's the one
and we also have a new england new
ingredient
called the size expansion trade off
which may be often dependent on the
interest
so in fact we have more results but i do
not have 10 50 scores for smaller
episodes we have more
algorithms
that decode
a little more errors and we also show
the list of decoding radius could be
larger than standard jonathan bond
or distance alpha and orbitals
okay that's all one single
result
so some open questions one is the
decoding algorithms for epsilon greater
than one quarter so as mentioned earlier
we have this boundary one by three if so
over one minus two if sometimes
walk
it actually holds for each room up to
one side
and for each one close to half vitamins
give an algorithm that would be called
sublinear errors okay that's the unknown
equal one
so one can ask
okay so then the next question will be
can we design these decoding algorithms
or
for expander codes or for ltpc
finally the last question will be
commercial is there any hardness result
for decoding or at least economy
that's all i want to say today
thank you